good evening and welcome to that guy
riffs today that guy looks at the first
cartoon ever to be made about Superman
entitled Superman sit back and enjoy
hey ie hi how about making the best
animated films that Nickelodeon's table
scraps can give us yes Superman the Man
of Steel the Son of Krypton disguised as
mild-mannered reporter Clark Kent
Superman spends most of his time trying
to get dookied from Lois Lane but she
won't put out until he marries so they
got married and lived in his Fortress of
sex attune but then they discovered that
Superman couldn't get it up in the sky
the Man of Steel was a floppy deal
Lois was crushed and wanted a divorce
but Superman refused to pay alimony and
wanted custody of the kids but Superman
couldn't get custody because of his
uncontrollable diction to jägerbombs
Superman tried to break in and steal his
kids but he was so drunk that he
accidentally broke into the home of
Bruce Wayne who fought him off with his
kryptonite nunchucks the Superman spends
most of his days punching his dog Krypto
drinking himself to oblivion well Lois
stands on the ledge of rooftops and
cries in the endless reaches of the
universe there once existed a planet
known as Krypton a planet that burned
like a green star in the distant heavens
they called it the sourball planet their
civilization was far advanced it brought
forth a race of supermen whose mental
and physical powers were developed to
the absolute peak of human perfection
but there came a day when giant quakes
threatened to destroy Krypton forever
one of the planet's leading scientists
sensing the approach of doom
his infant son on a small rocket ship
and sent it hurtling in the direction
but not exploded well more the planet's
dust bag filled up and exploded but
still explode the rocket ship sped
through star-studded space landing
safely on earth with its precious burden
Krypton's sole survivor hope they have
Wi-Fi a passing motorist found the
uninjured child and took it to an office
in withering height as the years went by
and the child grew to maturity he found
himself possessed of amazing physical
powers faster than a speeding bullet
Elly says when his girlfriend say a
locomotive overly tall buildings of a
singlet no idea I could do that the
infant of Krypton is now the Man of
Steel Superman
boy let's not build him up too much it
will best be in a position to use his
amazing powers in a never-ending battle
for truth and justice Superman has
assumed the disguise of Clark Kent
mild-mannered reporter for a great
metropolitan newspaper she can't open
his eyes either folks managing editor
managing editor managing editor can't I
want to see you just received another
threatening note ok mr. white
Lois another note from the mad scientist
coming in tea you called via radio
toaster a listen to this warning he
plans to strike tonight
beware you fools my electro fan Asia
race twice tonight at 12 total
destruction will come to those who
laughed at me and fail to heed my
warning to look at this longer than the
Three Stooges look at am at midnight
this nut may prove dangerous oh come on
how come everybody who threatens the
city with a death ray is a nut she may
have an angle on this thing yes sir but
chief I'd like the chance to crack the
story on my own oh thank you but Louis
below us I'm it suspicious the lessons
you think that's a dangerous mission
I'll just take the Daily Planet fighter
plane only I and Fox News have one of
these
rubber plane meanwhile at the Museum of
phallic looking buildings The Little
Mermaid poster is being put on display
oh I do hope they give me one million
dollars the hour has come it's time to
TiVo Rachael Ray
with my illusion 36 explosive space
modulator I'll be able to get a clear
view of Venus
whoa the bubbles are alive man haha
right there still lightning bugs outside
oh what's that
Timmy stuck in the well there's trouble
at the old mill there's a nosy reporter
with a personal jet landing just outside
my lair what what no I just want to blow
up one metropolitan city and suddenly
everybody wants a quote from you I'm so
ticked off that I'm molting
just wasn't very smart him to leave his
forwarding address on that evil letter
spa
you know more layers should come with
Bulger locks unreported sir I'm not a
Jehovah's Witness
I'm gonna hurry this up
I heard there's some witch that got
crushed by Seven Dwarfs just north from
here so you want a story I'll give you
the greatest story of destruction the
world has ever known
I'm going to bring back Jersey Shore
don't try to stop me it's already begun
okay don't still death way software Jeff
Chris won what of course I'm sure
why would I install death ray if I
wasn't sure but now great now the
program stopped working send an error
report whoever sends a goddamn error
report
kids what you're right Desiree how is
that for a story miss lane
it's Brandon working in human interest
true to assert the mad scientist whose
warnings of Elder sitting in a grip of
terror went on his rampage of
destruction of a stroke of midnight if I
we can locates a giant looming tower
from which he is using his death ray
Clary's and pedestrians into the river
below the police have warned everyone to
remain in their homes this looks like a
job for Superman too bad I have no
interest though let's see if Wonder
Woman's on duty let's see oh god what
did the janitor do in here did that come
from a human oh it's repugnant after
applying his Hitler mustache Superman
makes to the window to save the day all
right off the other way there has to be
another building in the city as phallic
as my to destroy hello
uh-uh personal day
I'll be alright now
oh she's filling what you've been eating
thank God that building was made out of
flexible sandpaper well I'd better take
off now oh just kidding just kidding
would that be funny if I just let you
guys fall like that haha in all
seriousness though the cost of rocking
this building is probably turn your bows
too gently so I'm just gonna get out of
here
and yet Bryan Singer still can't make an
interesting film about him don't ask me
how I know I just have a feeling you
know this is looking more like how Doc
Brown makes ice team
nothing can stop the strongest man in
the world God uncle oh jesus don't hurt
me
oh come on my caves over my head I can't
even see who it is on kryptonite and
whatever the hell this thing is will be
my only weakness Wow
Superman fights off the mighty beam of
light by simply punching it
remember kids brute violence always wins
over scientific understanding it's
almost as if he's super a Superman if
you will when I'm science yeah
yeah all i need's with my speaker kepta
laws of physics and Bugs Bunny cartoons
don't fail me now
Avon calling
mechanical hotdog bun is about to blow
I never had this problem with Super
Grover you know Bo it's call about a
pepper spray ever think of that
I tell them for cocoa puffs now watch
the incredible flying Man of Steel take
the stairs
hello my spinal cord but hey you can set
me down by that big comfy brothel over
there you know this is what John Cleese
has to look at every day
jaysus one fractured skull later
really so his parents named him mad
scientists isn't that sort of
pre-programming his future occupation
modulations noise that was a great
school yes gee thanks to Superman I've
waked if I had the ability to widen my
pupils the vulture scientists or
buildings made out sandpaper were harmed
in the filming of this episode